it worked very very well for four years
and then our ability to a component on
the spacecraft broke that destroyed our
ability to keep it aimed at that part of
the sky very carefully yeah
so we ended up with only four words so
those are called reaction wheels
reaction wheels just steer this basic
aware of them mm-hmm there were four and
we and we ended up having to break on us
in 2013 to broke well one broken in 2012
and then the second one broke in 2013 to
be exact and then you were still able to
from that point continue well that what
we were not able to do was continue
looking at the same part of this guy
okay we were not able to so that data
collection ended and so that's what we
called the Kepler prime mission that was
a couple of Crimean then that was about
four years of the 150,000 stuff that's
happened you look somewhere else for the
next well so so we thought of course in
2013 when the when we lost the ability
to point accurately you thought oh my
god it's over that's it but then we but
then people said well but you still have
two of these reaction wheels which can
help you help you even in you know two
ways that the problem is you have to
control your attitude in space in three
dimensions right and but with two
reaction wheels you can only do two
something ok well the people who built
the spacecraft at Ball Aerospace they
thought long and hard about this problem
and after couple months they came up
with the this absolutely crazy sounding
scheme which is what they did said they
said hey you know what if we point in
the direction of the orbit or opposite
the direction of the orbit either way
works if we point the spacecraft in the
direction of the orbit we can actually
balance the solar light pressure so
light from the Sun that wow we can
actually balance a spacecraft balance a
telescope using the solar light pressure
so long as we're pointed in the
direction of the orbit or opposite the
direction if you are because it's sort
of one big team and so they came up with
a scheme to use the light pressure from
the Sun to substitute for one of the
reaction wheels oh my god and then we
use the other two reaction wheels to
keep it pointed exactly what we want and
then let and then and then there's just
the tiny bit of roll and then what we do
is we use the actual thrusters on the
spacecraft to control the roll yeah by
firing the thrusters every 6 or 12 hours
had a little bit of limited amount of
thrust their capacity so every 6 to 12
hours only a couple years we started
this mode in late 2013 and it's still
going no way yeah absolutely oh wait
it's been five years been running five
years in this mode it's what holy cow
what we call the pay to mission okay
different name because it's a totally
different concept unfortunately it can't
just pick one started a part of this guy
and stare for four years that because as
you orbit the Sun you know you gotta
keep pointed in the direction of the
orbits but but the ball guys were really
clever they came up with a way to keep
us looking at one spot for as much as 90
days at a time
ninety days 90 days hein and then you
turn turn oh my gosh and now so it's so
interesting because we go up with the
intention to look at one patch and all
of a sudden there's a solution they
witness humans the advance we're now
looking 90 days at a time in a new patch
every times a new patch or are we
we've been we're a little opportunistic
what we do is we say we can look sort of
that direction and and the the
difference with the k2 mission is we no
longer think of it as just planet
finding we think of it as a general
astronomy observation mission and so
what we do is we say hey we can kind of
look in this direction and we ask the
astronomers in the world what would
what's in that direction that you'd like
to look at and we find we find a
particular direction to point that
catches as many of people to astronomers
desires as we can so we'll look at that
patch for a while and then we'll ask the
same question over in that direction and
and so sometimes when we come back
around we'll look at the same patch okay
so one look at it sometimes will look
slightly different awesome and so that's
been five years